finally it's been a cold and snowy
winter ross
yeah burr i know but a young boy in
rhode island decided to go
outside and no he wasn't building a
snowman
ten-year-old christian stone was at the
hospital clearing snow
off the cars of essential workers
and christian's mom amanda and a family
friend abby
were also out there helping christian
and they're all joining us now
so please welcome christian amanda and
abby
hi everybody
christian this was all your idea and
i just want to ask what gave you the
idea what made you want to go and help
the frontline workers
well the everyone that works at the
hospital has to deal with covet all day
and like all the other diseases and
stuff and they probably just want to get
home from work
so that would make it a step easier for
them by just you know
fixing up like just doing this they
don't have to do it
the fact that you know that obviously
amanda as his mom i
think that you're really doing things
right and you might thank you i'm
so proud i mean do you have any advice
for
other parents like me um
i'm definitely very proud i just have
always tried to raise him to be kind to
others and
to just realize that maybe something as
small as
wiping off cars can actually make
somebody's day
um you don't really know what struggles
other people are going through
so the smallest thing can make that have
the biggest impact
um i love that the smallest thing can
and for so many people who don't
know what they can do to help a little
thing like this can go such a long way
i'm wondering when you were out there
clearing the windows did you see any of
the doctors or nurses looking out like
what are you doing yeah abby you were
there what did you see
yes um so while we were cleaning the
cars uh chris
came up with the game anytime we saw the
headlights go on
we would try and rush over that car
before they came out cause they're
warming up their car so we would go and
start their car they would come out
and uh that's when we went up to them
christian told them what we were doing
and i had said that you know your
storm's inside
or storms out here we'll handle it from
here get in your car and get warm and
we'll take care of it from here
your storm's inside come on
such an inspiration and we want to send
you guys like on a family vacation
is that okay
yeah i'm best friends yeah okay great
perfect
all right you're gonna go on a five
night six day
stay at the lego land resort in florida
because i just feel like you deserve to
go have some fun
legoland that's right you're gonna stay
there at the new legoland
pirate island hotel with the
all-inclusive package including
meals from chicken checkout
daily admission passes to the theme park
and
the water park too
[Applause]
yeah that's for you
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you
[Music]
you